uh so i went fishing this weekend i know
i know we were talking about a trash
chase fishing special i'm i'm sorry guys
i can't believe you do that too
where the [ __ ] was my invite ask me lynn
maylin was one who invited me mainly
what the [ __ ]
i blame
i trusted you maylene
yeah melin just uh invited us uh me and
sydney if we wanted to have like a kind
of kind of like a double date where uh
we go fishing together and uh i really
[ __ ] enjoyed it i look like you're
enjoying it you're like you're about to
shoot yourself on the boat oh oh yeah so
like okay so this is
like so this is the first time where i
went sea fishing so it wasn't like it
wasn't uh fishing in a river or a lake
which i've done
so
so it is it is an entirely different
experience right mostly because
i've never been seasick in my life right
and we were talking about this so on on
the journey up there everyone's like oh
does anyone here get seasick which is if
you get seasick and you're about to go
fishing on the sea probably a bad idea
yeah yeah but none of us had ever been
seasick before so we're like great
fishing on a c easy um what we didn't
realize is what what i didn't realize is
that
when you're actively doing doing things
and having to concentrate things on top
of being on the sea and being on the
edge of a boat it like amps up your
seasickness to 10. so this is the first
time i've ever felt queasy on a boat
right
um
but i mean the uh the entire thing was
like aside from having to deal with the
seasickness it was it was pretty damn
fun so what happened is we
uh we went down to yokohama and we went
to the port there
and so we had they we have they have
this package where you basically go out
to sea for about four hours
uh i think it was like yeah about about
four years
yeah decent amount of time and basically
whatever you catch you can keep and you
can do whatever you want with the fish
so back when i went fishing uh in
wisconsin we have whatever we call we
could only keep a certain amount but
here you can like keep whatever you want
and you can cook them afterwards as well
um and so yeah so we went out to see um
and i remember at the beginning
so it was me sydney malin and marky
right and
so obviously it was our first time so
the fishman was trying to teach us how
it was done yeah right and within the
first hour maelyn catches two
immediately right and she's she she's
just she's just on fire right now she's
like
i'm a [ __ ] natural i'm a [ __ ]
natural imagine how smart yeah she was
so [ __ ] smug uh didn't catch anything
for the rest of the trip
it's like karma compilation yeah
and like and like on the opposite side
of things which was sydney and while
melin was like catching her first two
with him now sydney was like struggling
to get like the real down right like
like
the the fisherman was like next to her
for like a full-on hour like explaining
to her then explaining her to her again
yeah and like like here he was like
eagle-eyed on her just trying to make
sure that she was doing everything
correctly because she was not getting
any catches
um and then somehow like after an hour
in she just starts [ __ ] reeling and
fish like it's no business she starts
catching like four or five fish at the
end of it learns the controls
can finally play the game
and then there's maki uh which uh poga
who's maiden's husband monkey a poor guy
caught i i think i think he caught like
one fish at the end yeah and so did i i
actually no actually i caught like three
or four but most of them were two well
that's very different to one
i caught one fish that i could keep and
the rest were just like too small to
even like to even be worth right right
kills babies because stabs them throws
because because maki unfortunately was
like way too seasick to be able to
function for most of the trip yeah which
is which which is
which is the thing which is the thing
where melin uh melin also was seasick
and so aside to be fair uh but mainland
being melin was didn't want to admit it
because uh she she uh she was like
really silent after about an hour and
she was just sitting down and i was like
man you're right and she was like yep
yep i'm cool i'm just i'm just uh just a
little bit tired a little bit tired uh
she told me afterwards that she just
didn't want to admit she was seasick in
case like me or cindy would be like oh
no oh little baby
for seasickness yeah you can you can
which we would totally would have done
anyway
but as soon as soon as maki mentioned
that he was feeling seasick she turns to
me and cindy was like maki seasick she's
seasick i'm taking care of maki he's
and i'm just like i'm seasick as well
you know obviously i'm i'm not you know
it's it's normal to get seasoned
like
it was so funny because uh maki did uh
the marquis first catch right uh he
um he reeled in two little like super
small fish they were like baby fish
right they were like this big you know
you can't you can't do anything with
them so it's like at this point you just
catch and release everything yeah and it
was the first like baby fish we caught
on the day and this was about two hours
in and so he caught them and i was like
oh look at the little baby fish though
you know we should probably probably
release them so we uh he takes the hook
out and
he starts like he puts them back in the
ocean and they start swimming off and i
swear to god this thing's like this is
like a scene from the simpsons right you
can see them swimming off and sydney in
her little in her little you know you
know when sydney is just like talks
about a dog or talks about any animal
she's like go swim little baby swim swim
and then as soon as she finishes saying
that out of nowhere a seagull appears
and just dive bombs the fish out of the
water
and eats it
and the four of us are just
we're just standing there looking at
this [ __ ] atrocity in silence
and we're just like
well [ __ ]
it
yeah it's it's it's the circle of life
seagull annihilates tiny people nature
has been restored
my god oh but it was actually like it
was actually like a really fun
experience how much was it to go out on
the boat it was like about a hundred
dollars so per person per person
and you can catch as much fish as you
want and
and afterwards so you go catch the fish
and um
afterwards you uh they have different
services
so off so you can go to an uh izakaya
where they can cook the fish or you can
go to an onsen
and uh so there's this onsen that we
went to which is perfect for like if
you're fishing for four hours it's
surprisingly tired oh yeah it's like way
more fishing on the sea is way more
active than doing lake fishing
or river fishing right because you're
you're basting against the current and
you're constantly like it's way more
it's way more active because uh i don't
know what they call it but they they
gave you the like this little cage right
so you got the bait which is on the hook
and then next to the bait is this little
cage where you basically stuff in
um stuff in like fish like dead fishes
or
chuck oh is that what it's called yeah
okay okay so
oh that oh that's why it's called a chum
bucket
oh my god it makes so much sense now
chum is like just
mashed up fish yeah so they gave us a
chum bucket i guess i i was i was
struggling to find the worst describe
this [ __ ] thing it's a chum bucket
man discovers spongebob for the first
time
so we we had a chum bucket and so we had
to fill up this cage full of chum and
the the cage itself
would uh attract the fish school with
the smell and the bait itself would like
attract the fish uh to bite on it yeah
unfortunately like the chum would like
disintegrate within like you know within
like a good five five minutes so like
every every every five minutes you'd
have to like put it down
pick it back up put it down pick it back
up
uh
fill it up fill it up again fill up the
chamber uh fill up the chum cage with
more chum from your chum buckets and so
it was actually like way more of an
activity that's what god's new favorite
word is now i'm gonna be feeling like
we're gonna be hearing this a lot
and so it was a way more active
uh it was made way more active than
the other kind of fishing i experienced
so i was actually pretty tired um i was
it was i worked up a good sweat and my
god the onsen afterwards
[Music]
you know you know how you know how after
a hard day's work or how you've done
like you know after a hard day's work
god catches one baby fish damn that was
a hard damn hard day's
[Applause]
i did catch one fish i caught the
biggest fish of the day oh sydney caught
the most fish but i caught the biggest
fish
which was the tastiest though huh was
yours the taste mine was of course it
was mine of course what fish did you
catch um the tasty one
what type of food you have uh i can't
remember the type of fish i had i
believe it was a sea fish look at that
you remember the type of fish that we
were catching
a tiger
oh that's not the shitty cheap fish
right that's like the
the taste though right yeah that's the
[ __ ] you put in the can but that's like
the cheap like when you go to sushi
places that's like the cheapest one yeah
when you cut it open it's like really
really white with the uh silver outline
right it's like the it's like the blue
with like a little bit of yellow in the
fish i think yeah i'm totally wrong
maybe i'm just [ __ ] well like they do
have like different services where you
can catch different types of fish but
like the good fish that sounds cool
though i'd like to do that the good
things
yeah
special you know oh yeah next time
because
next time because uh you go to this
onsen and while you're in the onsen just
chilling out with the boys or whatever
they're preparing your fish right so
they take your fish and uh
and so they take take your catch and
they feed it to you uh afterwards which
is really the way they feed it what you
said that just made me i had the
immediate image of somebody coming out
there
open your mouth here comes the airplane
which is which is great i mean
what what better what better spice can
you why didn't you catch monkfish in
runescape that is a high level fish
or shark you can't catch like 15 fishing
or something you know it wasn't high
enough level you can't catch you just
leveled up that fish yeah yeah you can
catch different types of fish but the
best fish come out at like 7 00 a.m so
it's like a 7 a.m
when i'm just like it's always you know
what i'd like to try fishing
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's like after you
know five tries or something that's
that's when you're like dedicated that's
one you have like your own fishing rod
and all that [ __ ] you know
you know you know you're legit when
you've got your own equipment yeah yeah
yeah
fishing orders just one of those
devices that i feel like is such a big
investment just because of how annoying
it is to maintain oh yeah and like that
[ __ ] breaks so easily also like when you
get like super serious there's like
different rods for different fish yeah
yeah it's like oh my god it's like
i learned that from tales of rice i'm
sure i'm you know i'm sure when i'm if
i'm if i'm 50 and i haven't decided the
hobby yet i think as a white person that
is the default hobby i have
yeah i think oh yeah when i get to 50
we'll see that and golf or like the two
things i'm gonna be like yeah we'll see
if i have a hobby by then i don't know
maybe i will you don't have a hobby now
i can't be streaming
is that that old guy who's like used to
stream runescape a lot
because i'm the one that keems stuff
yeah the one that came out try to
[ __ ] cancel he still streams right
i'm pretty sure i think so
yeah so you know there's a future man i
i mean maybe i'm already like low on
energy now there's lots of people who
want me to be i'm sure man you say that
but you stream more than me and joey
combined
i feel like i'm really low on energy but
then you guys always don't stream much
so i don't know maybe i think there's a
difference between low on energy and
can't you know not being [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah right it's like i'm not low on
energy i just can't be [ __ ] yeah maybe
maybe yeah yeah i mean i i can't tell if
i'm like i am low on energy
because i have to like who am i kidding
who am i kidding i have to conserve my
energy for trash taste people think i
talk a lot and then no it's just like i
can serve all my all my like social
energy for [ __ ] trash taste every
week and then i like i've reset every
week
it's hard work in this in this show
honestly though if i stream then that's
my work done for the day because i can
do it in the night
how do i have energy after i've been
working all day to also stream which is
to me work
sometimes you start streaming and then
you just kind of get energy as you're
streaming i get that sometimes it
happens like sometimes i'm really
dreading it's called being an extrovert
like literally it's like you're getting
you're gaining the energy you're
shifting the energy yeah you know that
you're stifling the energy from social
interaction right
for me it's the opposite like i have a
certain amount of energy and i have to
expel that during the day basically
expel expel
[ __ ] it out
[ __ ] out we have this [ __ ] out of my
energy
no more [ __ ] we promised no more
[ __ ]
just like god goes to the toilet and
sydney's like are you expelling your
energy honey
during my energy exploration period